hello we're glad you've joined us for
this webinar next-generation sequencing
of the immune system from single cells
to bulk repertoire i am michelle
ashen of lab herbs and i'll be
moderating this session today's
educational web seminar is presented by
bobrucz the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration it's presented
by Beckman culture to learn more about
our sponsor please visit the UW Beckman
comm let's get started you can post
questions to the speaker during the
presentation to do so simply put them
into the drop down box located on the
far left of your screen labeled ask a
question and click on the send button
questions will be answered after the
presentation to enlarge the slide window
click on the arrows at the top right
hand corner of a presentation window if
you experience technical problems seeing
or hearing the presentation just click
on the support tab found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problems by typing it into
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain the credits I now
present today's speaker Miranda Byrne
skills the director of the R&D and
operations at I repertoire Inc to learn
more about our speaker please visit the
speaker tab at the top of the
presentation window Miranda you may now
begin your presentation
hello everyone and welcome I'd like to
take this opportunity to thank my
friends at Beckman Coulter for the
invitation to give this presentation
over the years I repertoire has
increasingly incorporated Beckman
reagents and robotics into our workflow
which has really improved or sensitivity
inclusiveness and repeatability so today
I'm going to explain how I repertoires
technology can be used to capture really
important information from the body's
immune system from the single cell all
the way through immune repertoire
analysis
so the the immune system is at the
forefront of environmental and genomic
interactions and the adaptive immune
system specifically the B and T cells in
the adaptive immune system can actually
rearrange their genomic DNA so that they
come out very specific and rapid in
responses to environmental challenges I
really like this picture because Tamiya
points to the balance the immune system
has to achieve in order to get this
measured response so for instant when an
organism encounters an external threat
like a virus or bacteria if the response
is too strong inflammation will result
which can result ultimately in tissue
damage if the response is under
responding then the organism can succumb
to infection likewise were constantly
challenged with internal threats damaged
cells damaged DNA damaged proteins and
the body has to be able to recognize
these but if their body over responds to
these threats we develop autoimmunity
which ultimately result also in tissue
damage or if we under respond we can
develop cancer which is out of control
cell growth
okay so I repertoire since 2009 and 2009
has been developing multiplex PCR
technologies that capture the variable
gene region from B and t-cell receptors
the receptor whether it's a B or T cell
is a heterodimeric protein that is on
the surface of the cell or in the case
of B cells that can actually be excreted
into the blood plasma it is comprised of
two chains two different chains at the
surface of the protein whether it's a
t-cell receptor or a b-cell receptor one
of the chains is more complex consisting
of a diversity segment at the diversity
segment and J region and the Lexx
complex chain which consists of a VJ
rearrangement it's together that these
two chains form the actual receptor and
it's important to note that at the RNA
level these two pieces of information
are actually not connected with one
another the variable region that we
target is generated from the recombinant
a combination event at the genomic DNA
level of one B gene from many options
one D gene from additional options in
one J gene and together these can be
combined with various constant region
genes here I show a b-cell receptor but
there's actually a similar recombination
event on the T cell receptor additional
mechanisms increase the diversity of the
DJ rearrangement site such as in
addition and nibbling and with b-cells
the heavy chain can undergo a process
called hyper mutation across the entire
variable region this makes it important
to capture that a variable region so
that you can capture these hyper
mutation events which can further
increase the binding of the b-cell
receptors to the actual target
a tie repertoire are covered to the
variable region is compatible with
aluminum next-generation sequencing and
is perfectly sized for many of the kits
offered through Illumina we have short
read kits which capture just the CD or
three so they begin within framework
three to the beginning of the C gene are
longer read kids and mouse capture from
within framework to to the beginning of
the see gene and her long read TCR and
BCR kits for human capture from within
framework one to the beginning of the C
gene and importantly in b-cell receptors
we are also able to capture the ISO type
information in addition to hyper
mutation events
okay so when I talk about single cell
what do actually I mean versus bulk
repertoire and why a single cell so
important I alluded to it on the
previous slide when I said that the
protein at the surface is a heterodimer
composed of two different chains but
when we think about the cell and the way
we normally handle cells we break open
the cells or lyse them and all of the
contents spill into the vesicle at that
point I have a huge loss of information
problem
I no longer know at the RNA level which
receptor of the heavy chain is matched
with its light pair or on the T cell
receptor
I no longer know which alphas match with
each beta or each Delta with each gamma
so in order to get that information back
if I think of single cell as a pieces of
fruit I can if I treat each cell is its
own in its own reaction I can actually
call the heavy and light chain pair or
the TCR alpha and beta pair additionally
I can actually start to delve in depth
into the actual cell and start to tell
you is it a Kiwi is it a raspberry is it
a blueberry meaning I can actually call
the phenotype of each single cell
whereas when I do both repertoire both
Grabber tuara has a lot of information
about diversity however I can no longer
tell which heavy chain matches which
light chain which alpha matches which
beta and that can be important if you're
planning to do functional assays
downstream
right so in order to address this issue
we've developed a service that Co
captures the b-cell receptor having at
my chain or the t-cell receptor alpha
and beta chain from single cells in
96-well pcr plates and the service is
called I pair it's based off of our
ample con rescue multiplex PCR
technology we're both receptors are Co
amplified in a single cell which is
deposited into a 96-well plate so
briefly I'm going to go over the
features of the AI pair service so
there's a couple of options that our
clients will use when sending us cells
they can either sort folks sort the
cells at their site and send to us and
we will single cell deposit into AI
capture plate but if they have very few
cells and they're not already doing the
sorting experiment many of them will
actually take their cells and I capture
plate on height and they'll single cell
deposit at the time of sorting they send
us the plates or they send us the cells
if we're going to actually do the single
cell plating and we perform the amplicon
rescue multiplex PCR technology and I'll
go into the details of that in just a
second however is an overview we perform
reverse transcription in PCR one and
96-well format we then index each well
of the PCR plate during PCR two we
perform a cleanup
the libraries are pulled together and
their sequence using alumina next
generation sequencing the data is mapped
and reported in what we call the IP air
analyzer and the AI pair analyzer really
helps and facilitate the viewing of the
particular alpha beta vdj rearrangements
in each well and thus each single cell
so how does this work so as I mentioned
just a moment ago it's based off of
amplicon rescued multiplex PCR it's a
nested meaning there's outside and
inside primers reverse transcription PCR
included on the inside primers is an
inline plate barcode which we use to
actually barcode multiple plates so we
can stack multiple plates into the same
sequencing run now we use armed PCR in
both repertoire we made some
modifications for single cell we
modified the primer set so that both low
sigh alpha and beta can be amplified
under the same conditions or ID heavy
capital and under the same condition so
there Co amplified in the same well
there Co amplified under low reaction
volume and we swapped out the adapters
so that they were compatible with
Illumina dual indexing because this dual
indexing is what's going to allow us to
map back to that individual well the PCR
plate
so as I said before we're performing
amplicon rescued multiplex PCR and we're
actually doing this with a reagent
called spry select beads from Beckman so
what we do is we perform the reverse
transcription PCR one and we rescue that
entire bead product using veteran
culture spry select beads these beads
are then brought into PCR - which I'll
go over momentarily but before I do that
I want to show you an experiment as to
how much these beads can actually
increase the amplification sensitivity
this is an agarose gel image and the
band at about 500 base pairs this nice
bright band on the right is the band
that we want this band on the bottom at
about 180 base pairs is actually called
primer dimer we don't want that so all
of these amplicons came from the same
rt-pcr one product in the first two we
just transferred two microliters of pcr
one product into the second PCR we
didn't know Spri be clean up in between
in the middle portion of the jell we had
an unwise by select protocol and finally
at the end of the gel we have the
optimized version so all are starting
with the same template but as you can
see you get dramatically different
results by increasing the sensitivity of
the bead selection we're actually able
to increase the number of successful vbj
calls that we get and thus we can
increase our pairing alpha beta or IG
heavy capital and a success rate at
single-cell
so we also incorporated automation into
the processing of these 96-well pcr
plate I don't think I have to tell many
people that it's kind of a bear to
process a 96-well PCR using a
multi-channel pipette not only is it
time-consuming because you have to if
you're using an eighth strip or a 12
strip but it also is error-prone so one
of the features we liked about Beckman
there were several features but the
first is that it had a 96-well head and
so that we could process all wells at
the same time thus decreasing the actual
amount of time that it takes to process
the plates we also can decrease the
reaction volumes because we're able to
accurately process each individual well
go down to about three microliters we
can avoid cross-contamination and we can
reduce our consumable usage by reusing
our tips
this is resulted in very consistent
results in the next slide I'd like to
are in the next slide I'd like to show
you a little video that shows some of
the features of the actual robot that we
have in hand it's a biomech I 5 so we'll
show the robot now in action
okay so the video showed some of the
functionalities of the i5 robot and I do
feel that the movie does speak louder
than a static image so you saw that the
robot was capable of load volume
transfer and we were able to mix the
beads with the PP or PCR products using
a pipetting very efficiently but for me
one of the important features is that we
can actually reuse those 96-well tips
really reducing or consumable costs
because if I'm going to use those tips
again for another wash I can actually
just tween wash them and put them back
into their original slots which allows
us to basically cut down from you
needing ten boxes of tips if we were
doing this manually to one box and
finally I thought the gripper arm was
really cool because it's capable of
picking up non skirted plates and we
like these plates because they're
divisible so we can actually score a
portion of the plate and test on a
portion if we'd like to before beginning
the entire processing
so after PCR one and amplicon rescue is
completed we then proceed to PCR to the
during PCR one our primer sets had this
partial handle partial adapter sequence
included on it so the PCR products have
this handle we can then pick up the PCR
one product with a pair of primers this
pair of primers is going to have the
Illumina tool in debt indices on an i-5
and an i7 index and if you think of this
kind of like a map that's the best way
to think of it so if we're in well c2
that would have index 503 and 702 this
means that anything that's amplified in
that well we'll have that index and can
thereby be traced back to that well and
in this way we can trace back from one
single cell the Alpha bdj the beta vdj
to the same address or b cell looking at
the IG heavy and the Kappa lambda at the
same address this also allows us to look
at phenotype which I'll talk about in a
couple of slides where we can actually
add markers additional gene markers so
that we can start to tell what type of
fruit is it is it a Kiwi is it a
strawberry as a raspberry so we can add
these directly to the reaction and Co
amplify them with the Alpha and Beta
sequence or with the IG heavy and Kappa
lambda sequences
so one of the more difficult aspects of
developing the service was actually
establishing cell handling and shipping
conditions because a lot of
immunologists usually have very few
cells we're talking when the cells are
sorted sometimes as few as a thousand
cells sometimes it's a few hundred cells
typically on average I would say between
five and ten thousand cells however you
can't cryo preserve 5000 to 10,000 cells
without losing a lot of them and it's
really not recommended for less than a
million cells or 10 million cells even
so we had to come up with a way that we
could have cells shipped to us for
single-cell plating and I peer analysis
and we found a reagent called chitin RNA
protect cell reagent it's sold through
kaijin and we developed a proprietary
method where we could actually detect
intact cells from to cell debris and
plate directly single cell plate
directly from that region so in this
experiment we have 500 cells that are
been placed into 400 microliters of this
reagent and we just stuck it in the
refrigerator for 8 days and we were
mimicking shipping conditions and a 4
degree cooler so we took the cells out
of the refrigerator there jurkat cells
meaning they have one alpha and 1 beta
sequence of a very consistent sequence
and we equated these these 500 cells one
cell per well and we Co amplified the
Alpha and the beta and this is this
amplicon at 500 base pairs in the middle
of the well and each well is one single
cell and you can see after eight days at
four degrees we still have a hundred
percent amplification success rate
so as I said before we have a lot of
people who really want to know not just
what the BBJ rearrangement is for the
sell but actually what is the sell doing
in its environment to address this we
have two different types of technology
to answer what type of cell it is and
I'm going to go over the benefit and the
cons of both first we developed a gene
specific panel either primer pairs that
cover the targets in the left hand side
that is gene specific panel there's up
to 30 targets and not all 30 targets
have to be analyzed at the same time
these can be custom-made from anyone on
this list the benefit of these is that
you can add these primers to the
alpha-beta vdj amplifications rt-pcr one
reaction directly so the Alpha the beta
and these phenotyping primers can be
added all all together and Co amplified
which makes for less expensive
processing the bad part about this is if
one of those markers is actually over
expressed in the cell what will happen
is that that marker will get the
majority of the reads which can lead to
actually drop out on the vdj increasing
expense if you need to increase the
sequencing depth and it's not
predictable because each cell is its own
template so each cell we we don't know a
priority what the actual expression is
going to be what the expression profile
is so we therefore developed another
panel which actually allows for more
targets is called an oligo DT panel and
instead of doing the reverse
transcription with the immune specific
primers we actually start our Ligety T
panel with reverse transcription from an
oligo DT primer we then split the
amplification into two plates one plate
goes for bdj pairing just like I showed
before and the other plate actually has
a primer mix that covers various gene
markers up to 100 so that these can be
analyzed independently of the bdj
therefore the sequencing can be
performed independently of the vdj which
actually helps reduce dropout on the
receptor pair
so in order to view the results we also
developed a GUI called the IP air
analyzer and I'm going to spend a few
moments talking about the I pair
analyzer because that will come up again
later in the talk and when you first
open it you get a full plate view and
the colors on the plate actually
demonstrate the genes that are expressed
so if a well is blue only it means a TCR
alpha was called if it's purple of TCR
alpha and beta and if it's if it's red a
TCR beta the same color scheme can be
performed with IG heavy Kappa lambda any
of these wells you can click on the well
so in this case it's clicked here and
you'll see a report of the CDR 3 that's
where the DJ rearrangement is that's a
translated amino acid of the TCR alpha
and the TCR beta if I click on these I
actually get a view and it searches the
entire plate for that particular pair so
if there is clonal expansion meaning one
clone is actually dominant in the sample
it will show up on the plate as multiple
instances of a circle and a diamond that
overlap so maybe this well if it had a
circle and a diamond would be an
instance of clonal expansion if it
showed up more than once on the plate
but also below you get it to build your
own table for those targets that you
want to go on and clone and Express for
functional studies so you can look
through the plate clear the table
actually build the plate with build the
table with only those wells of interest
and then export the read information for
those wells for downstream cloning and
expression for I've here plus we also
offer heat maps and Disney plots so that
we can look at the relationship of the
genes and the various cells so now I'm
going to actually show you an example
that's really exciting of the
development of the first human
monoclonal antibody against Plasmodium
falciparum PFS 230 antigen so this story
was really interesting I was not aware
of what transmission blocking vaccines
were until dr. Coachella called me on
the phone
I'm asking for help with a project her
timing was perfect because we had just
completed the actual Rd necessary to
release I pair b-cell receptor on
single-cell analysis so transmission
blocking vaccines are very interesting
they prevent transmission by
the blood meal from which the the
malarial infected mosquito eats you so
if the mosquito bites you and sucks in
the blood and you've been exposed to
this vaccine you've developed
neutralizing antibodies against that
cosmo d impulsive and when the mosquito
intakes that blood it actually can kill
the malaria in the gut of the mosquito
so they were actually looking to
identify the B cell receptors a very
rare memory B cells from from adults who
were administered this vaccine and
showed responsibility the actual
Plasmodium falciparum antigen so these
adults had received four vaccinations
and kamila was able to identify upwards
only like 50 to 100 memory b-cells
antigen specific memory of B cells out
of 5 million PBMC so obviously she
needed a way that she could look at the
receptors as these 50 memory B cells
that she was finding per patient and
originally she was going to use booked
repertoire but luckily I convinced her
that it was worthwhile to do single cell
and we perform the single cell
experiments and for the first time I had
ever seen on b-cells that we had clonal
expansion of different b-cells on the
plate so we might have one clone that
shows up 3 times another that shows up 2
times another that showed up 2 times so
we started to see these clonal expansion
of b-cells which I had never seen before
because usually primary b-cells are very
very diverse and these cells were very
very rare they were 50 out of 5 million
PBMCs that she was pulling out of these
patients so in her case she single cells
sorted at the time of sorting G single
cell plated and sent us the plates and
we performed the IPR PCR on this plate
well obviously our next question was
well are these actually reactive against
the OP Plasmodium falciparum antigen
and we did a very quick in-house at I
record it a very quick reverse
transcription and translation and made
fab fragments for five of the selected
targets based on clonal expansion of the
different b-cells and what we
demonstrated was that at least four out
of the five or 80% of them were actually
binding to the to the antigen so at
NIAID they went and made a full-scale
antibody for two of the top or the most
dominant commonly expanded b-cells and
what they found is one of these
antibodies actually can eliminate 99% of
the Kamata sites and the the various
forms of the Plasmodium falciparum at
low concentration of protein so it's
very very exciting and that work should
be coming out soon so one of the biggest
issues with obviously doing a low
throughput service like this is that you
can only analyze 96 cells at a time now
this is fantastic if the cells are very
rare or you have a way to pull down the
specific antigen specific cells of
interest however if we want to analyze
more than a few thousand cells we need
to go to a higher throughput method so
I'll also introduce our high to put
single cell pairing and phenotyping
service that we're developing based off
the beedi rhapsody so the beauty
Rhapsody is an interesting cartridge
based single cell system it has micro
Wells where you can load single cells in
the micro well and one cell per well is
loaded with one bar coded bead
the cells are lysed the RNA is captured
onto that beam and then the beads are
all transferred into one small Eppendorf
tube and the RNA is reversed transcribed
such that each bead and therefore all of
the RNA will contain the same barcode on
that bead
the beads are reusable this means that
we can actually perform an alpha
amplification a beta amplification of
phenotyping amplification all from the
same bead set
as long as we capture the cell bar code
during sequencing we can trace all of
that information together so this allows
so that bdj pairing is through our own
proprietary strategy and technology but
we're using the BD rhapsody kids in
order to and their bees in order to get
this cell barcode information this also
supports simultaneous RNA and protein
measurement so you can actually add
proteins that are labeled with an elite
AG or a poly a tag I'm sorry and but we
haven't explored that option yet as we
were developing the TCR Alpha and the
beta so from some of our initial
experiments this is one initial
experiment where we're looking at
monocyte depleted cd4 positive cells we
loaded 15,000 of those cells and we were
in the end able to identify 9,000
barcodes from eight different route
amplification replicates on the beta and
12 different amplification replicates on
the Alpha we averaged nine thousand TCR
beta CD or three and six thousand TCR
alpha CDR threes to identify a total of
2652 pairs from those nine thousand cell
barcodes
some of our initial experiments were for
validity so what we would do is we
looked at the actual BD data because we
have phenotyping data and we also have
our BD j data so looking at each chain
individually if we're looking at the TCR
beta CD or three and we look at the
phenotyping data from the BD 400 gene
kit the BD constant region gene should
overlap with the VD j of our TCR beta CD
or three and indeed we do find that and
we also can see a population that we're
missing it's the same with the CD or
three alpha we can look at the alpha CD
or three we can look at the constant
gene from BDS kit for the TCR alpha and
when we combine them we can see where
they overlap and the various populations
that we're missing on the BD j calling
for alpha and it actually turns out that
alpha is the one that's limited
our ability to pair the various PD days
if we looked look at the paired alpha
beta so we were looking in the previous
slide at individual beta chain and alpha
chain now if we look at the coincidence
of the alpha beta this is the B D alpha
C and beta C these cells have the Alpha
C and the beta C from the phenotyping
panel and here's the paired alpha beta
so there is a portion a subset of cells
that we are not calling the paired vdj
and we are still looking into that but
that will be coming soon as a service so
that you can analyze upwards of 20,000
cells as opposed to looking at 96-well
plates okay
so I have to mention here that single
cell really taught us a lot it taught us
a lot about amplification and about our
techniques and about sensitivity and
from our single cell experiments we
actually developed a new type of pcr
called dimer avoided multiplex PCR and
specifically we've started to apply this
to bulk repertoire amplification so
looking at all of those cells in this
all of that RNA in the smoothie using
this new technique so this is a single
cell gel and this is really where the
light bulb started to go off this is a
single cell gel using armed PCR where we
add these 30 additional phenotyping
markers to the actual reaction and what
you begin to see instead of the crisp
clear amplicon band that we were getting
before in some instances we would get
that and if you actually looked at the
sequencing data a majority of the
sequences were going to the phenotyping
genes of interest and to the targeted
vdj of interest with only 1% of the data
having what we would call trash where as
something that looks like a reasonably
good amplification would have 21% of the
data as not usable whereas something
that pretty clearly failed 89% was not
useful the other hint that we had when
we were trying to make all of these
different gene markers work together
under the same conditions
is that you can't design around the
actual byproducts of PCR because we went
through and we actually sequence the
dimers to see if we could see which
prayers are the culprits which are the
bad guys that are actually this
detriment to the actual signal of
interest and what we found was that one
base pair overlap was sufficient for
dimerization which means that it's not
you can't design around one base pair
it's impossible so you actually have to
have physical strategies that can
actually remove the dimers during the
processing so this is a very aha moment
for us on this slide which is basically
we're multiplexing together various
targets and what we found is that we
added one target and it removed the
amplified one primer remove the amplicon
of interest
well this was kind of an aha moment for
us because it wasn't that this was a
failed amplification it was actually a
successful amplification it was just the
amplification of the wrong product of
the primer dimer product during the PCR
so we developed a strategy called dimer
avoided multiplex PCR that uses physical
and chemical means throughout the entire
process to remove these side products
and by removing these side products were
then actually capable of getting very
crisp clean signal from single cells so
this is the same single cell experiment
that I showed on the previous two slides
ago however in this case each of these
is a single cell with 30 gene targets
however in this case we tried an
entirely different strategy called dimer
avoid at multiplex PCR and we can get
very crisp and clean signaling so we
realized that the multiplexing
capability with this type of technology
was limitless and we decided that we
could go after all of the different
immune chains in the same reaction
meaning that we weren't stuck to looking
at just TCR beta only or just PCR alpha
only we can now look at TCR alpha beta
Delta Gamma IG heavy and Kappa and
lambda all under the same reaction
conditions in a single reaction to the
method also supports unique molecular
indexing so we can actually tag each
strand of RNA with its own unique tag a
label enabling quantification downstream
and superior error removal this extreme
multiplexing power allows deep insights
into the immune system because now I can
look at all different chains at the same
time in the same from the same sample
and start to evaluate expression of B
cells versus T cells
the one downside the dimer avoided piece
multiplex PCR is that it is very
labor-intensive in terms of the
processing steps for chemically and
physically removing dimers throughout
the process and therefore we've
automated on two different platforms we
have the IR processor which is an
in-house processing system that is based
on cassettes individual cassettes which
I'll show in a few slides where the
reagents are preloaded and cassettes you
just add the sample put it in and it
will do the entire processing for larger
projects we use our biomech i-5 so that
we can process both repertoire 96-well
plates
so during the validation of this we
wanted to know how our strategy was
really capturing the immune repertoire
so in order to do that we actually
developed a all chain synthetic library
so this synthetic library was created by
amplifying every single pair of
amplicons of interest so say for
instance the TCR beta repertoire
required 50 TCR beta v primers and 2c
primers this is just an example we would
amplify all different 50 with each of
the c-- primer so 100 amplification
reactions we did this for every single
chain then we pulled a small amount of
each of those individual libraries
together to make a quote/unquote
synthetic library which wasn't amplified
further it was just sequenced directly
this library was then diluted to very
low concentration and used as a template
in a reaction as a control we used a
pair of primers for the adapters due to
a previous study we knew that by
amplifying using these universal primer
binding sites that we've added we should
be able to replicate the library
one-to-one or close to one to one then
we did our our strategy or dimer avoided
multiplex PCR strategy and with this
strategy we bind in one cycle and extend
using our first primer mix we clean we
add a second primer mix in which we bind
and extend clean again and then we
amplify using a pair of primers so the
entire exponential phase of
amplification is purely for the communal
adapters
so when we get the results back we can
compare everything to our synthetic
library so that synthetic library is
just a directly sequence fake immune
repertoire library and then it's been
diluted and re amplified using our two
strategies so on the repeatability we
can compare our synthetic library which
has no amplification to our control
amplification which is just the pair of
adapters on the outside and we get great
repeatability on the V gene usage
looking at just the TCR beta gene versus
the control the synthetic library it
replicates very well and over on the
right we show what's called the V usage
ratio plot which is a log based plot
which each of the V genes is is shown
with respect to the ratio of the
synthetic library and as you can see the
closer to 1 this line theoretically 1
would be no bias in the amplification
when we do the damned PCR method where
we're doing this binding an extension
step with cleaning up and binding an
extension cleaning in a second cycle
with the exponential phase of
amplification with the pair of primers
we actually replicate the synthetic
library very well again we get a similar
trend and the repeatability the V usage
looks as it should meaning we replicate
the repertoire as it was in the
synthetic library with very little bias
on the various B gene usages
so next we began to combine chains
together so we started to look at the
TCR what we call 14 TCR looking at alpha
beta Delta Gamma of four different
individuals
on the left here are different these are
different ratios of the various chains
alpha beta delta and gamma from one
individual are four different
individuals and this is zoomed in on one
individual to show the repeatability
down to even the low frequency clones
and as you can see it's got very good
repeatability our repertoire is known
for our our tree maps which are over on
the right what these tree maps show is
an individual Colonna types are each
individual square and the size of that
square is the relative expression of
that chronotype within the data set so
now instead of just having one chain to
display we now have four chains
Alpha Beta Delta and gamma so you can
actually see on one of these individuals
there was an expansion on Eire 91 on the
Alpha chain with respect to the beta
chain which was in red and this was very
interesting but now we have a whole slew
of immunological tools available to us
so what we were able to do is take that
patient single cell and actually go and
check to see whether there was something
interesting about the Alpha cells and
what we found is that there was a clonal
expansion of various dual alpha cells
within that person's blood and it
matched on the single cell level we also
had a really interesting Delta Gamma
expression in IR 89 we were able to go
to single cell and show that there was
also a clonal expansion of Delta Gamma
cells that had a high amount of RNA in
them and they were the same clue so the
actual single cell began to inform the
bulk repertoire and vice versa the bulk
repertoire began to inform the single
cell experiments we also so we knew one
of the best places to apply this
technology as one sample is limited or
damaged formalin-fixed paraffin-embedded
tissue is notorious in terms of RNA
integrity it has really poor integrity
and you don't often get a lot of RNA
because the samples have been sitting
for maybe years so we applied this
Evon chain where we Co amplify alpha
beta Delta Gamma in order to get insight
into that FFPE sample and not use all of
it so we're able to Co amplify and look
at the cloner types of not just the
b-cells
but also the t-cells within that FF to
each section
so you may be asking how would you gain
access to the technology you can gain
access to the products and services
offered through eye repertoire and I'll
very briefly go over those so we have
products services and automations
definitely our services are probably our
most popular single cell is only offered
through a service but in order to enable
our single cell we offer all the way
from cells staining to single cell
plating for the purposes of I pair we
have two types of I pair TCR and BCR in
human and in mouse we offer TCR we also
offer human and mouse I pair plus is
where we're phenotyping on the bulk
repertoire sequencing in order to enable
the possibility of doing both repertoire
there certain labs that aren't set up to
do actually RNA extraction so we can
actually perform the RNA extraction for
you and we can access the arm PCR
through our amp to seek services our
damn PCR technology with that multi
chain analysis and unique molecular
identifiers to our Harmony we've also
performed phage display library
sequencing for various people and other
custom NGS essays so if you have a
question you know please reach out to us
we're more than happy to work with you
to figure out the best solution for your
projects if you prefer to perform some
of these things in-house we do have bolt
primer mixes we have easy-to-use kits
called our profile kits that come with
all of the reagents necessary to amplify
your own immune repertoire and then to
enable single-cell plating at your site
we have an eye capture kit that we can
send out to you on that our automation
portion we have the IR harmony system
our the IR flex processor system which
enables you to add to sects into a
processing system that's like a
miniature liquid handler those cassettes
come preloaded with all the reagents
necessary you just add your template you
stick it in the instrument the
instrument does all of the steps reverse
transcription PCR one PCR one selection
PCR two and
a library clean up with the beads and
you just go and retrieve the library
pull them together and go on for
sequencing
so this is a picture of the IR processor
where we've automated bulk repertoire
the sample is added to this cassette
which is preloaded at the bottom with
the reagents it has a pipette tip in
here that can actually move reagents
back and forth and in this instrument we
actually it's like a PCR machine that
also has liquid handling capabilities it
it moves the pipette tip around based on
the script that's preloaded it performs
PCR 1 and PCR - and final library
cleanup within that all of our products
and services come with data analysis so
for bulk repertoire we have a viewing
service through it's called IR web it's
accessible through the website you get a
username and login you get B DJ C
mapping identification of CD or 3s and
CD or 3 algebra so that you can compare
across different samples in addition to
normal distributions that are provided
for me repertoire sequencing such as an
addition CD or three lengths BJ nibbling
and VJ usage and as I mentioned before
we also have the I pair analyzer which
allows you to build a table of
interesting sequences so that you can go
on to do cloning it's an expression
together with Disney plots and frequency
maps if you've added plus primer sets to
your project
so in conclusion it's important to note
that paired receptor information from
physically paired single cells provides
actionable information that can be
quickly screened that information can be
lost if you just do both repertoire but
if you sometimes combine the two it
gives you the information so that you
can actually go and make functional
proteins that you can test your
hypothesis after single cell level
clonal expansion is evident and
important we saw that in the malaria
study where various b-cells had expanded
and those are the ones that actually
found and cleared the Plasmodium
falciparum we're planning on increasing
both our human and mouse single-cell
offerings to include our Gamma Delta
pairing and also we're increasing or
expanding our legged DT based
phenotyping panels
so and based on what we've learned from
the single cell it allowed us to develop
the new type of technology and new type
of technique that allows us to look at
all of these immune receptor chains in a
single reaction so that one template can
be added or a small amount of template
can be added yet still get actionable
information and finally our
high-throughput single cell pairing
service is going to be available soon so
please check back with us frequently
we're very excited about that
we're located in coming to research park
in beautiful Huntsville Alabama at the
Hudson Alpha Institute for biotechnology
research campus yes that is a DNA helix
we are probably the only people in the
world who have a 1.4 mile double helix
walkway we're now located our repertoire
at the new Paul Prout Center which was
finished last October and we have
expanded quite dramatically so special
thank you to Beckman Coulter again and
thank you to the team at eye repertoire
and NIAID none of this research would be
possible without all of the people who
supported us throughout the years -
thank you all
Thank You Miranda for your informative
presentation we will now start the Q&A
portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
will answer as many questions as we have
time for let's get started all right our
first question is you ever see dual
alpha TCR single cells in your data and
if so what is the frequency okay
wow that's a great question so yes we do
see dual alpha TCR single cells actually
we've seen all different types of
combination I've seen dual beta with one
alpha I've seen dual alpha only I've
seen dual alpha with one beta um so yes
at the single cell level you can really
get a deeper insight into what's
happening on the T cell which could be
masked by bulk repertoire the frequency
portion of that question is very
difficult to answer because it seems to
be an individual to individual kind of
difference so when we did that
high-throughput pairing experiment one
of the things that we looked at is we
look side-by-side at the single cell I
paired data for that same individual and
I didn't show the data set there but
there's actually a population of cells
that look like they're TCR beta only and
they would look like there was a
population that were TCR alpha only and
indeed when we looked at the single set
and with the cell set we calculated how
many single cells were dual alpha in
that particular individual was twenty
percent dual alpha but actually dual
beta with no alpha was approximately ten
percent which actually matched the high
throughput pairing data um yeah so it's
a very interesting topic but we
definitely see dual alpha cells it's
just the frequency can vary person to
person or cell type to cell type
great thank you okay your next question
when you look at single cell alpha beta
T cells do you also see clonal expansion
as you did for the malaria study yes
absolutely
um so particularly when the cells like
just as in the malarial study in the
malaria study they catch them are sorted
positive sorted B single cells from the
B cell if the T cells are tetra more
positive or some antigen specific pull
down of the TCR s we definitely begin to
see clonal expansion within those
populations sometimes it can be as high
as a hundred percent of the clone be one
clone o-type but each be an individual
cell but it varies like I've seen as
fused five of the same TCR two of the
same TCR and various different clones
that have that you can directly count
the alpha beta of that particular pair
to as high as like I said before a
hundred percent of the clones being the
same type
thank you what is the minimal amount of
cells you require for single-cell
analysis
so this really depends on how you're
submitting the cells are the project to
us as I mentioned before in Camilla's
case she had 50 actually in one patient
she had 25 of these antigen specific
memory b-cells so in those cases it
really depends on your sorting facility
if you can sort at your site then you
can do as few as half of a plate for
submission that's our minimal submission
amount which I guess would be 48 so if
you're submitting to us we request a
thousand cells minimum but we can
certainly go over all those details if
you please reach out to us at info at I
report or comm we'll be happy to help
you set up a project and discuss this
further
thank you all right it looks like we
have time for one more question is
single cell an option for FFPE samples
okay so FFPE samples are very degraded
usually in the RNA so this is not
something that we have tested and I'm
not sure if it's going to be feasible or
not it's something that we're interested
in trying but we have not tested that
yet
thank you again Miranda for your time
today and your important research we
would also like to thank labyrinth and
our sponsor Beckman Coulter for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and
further interesting questions questions
we did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration laboratory alert
use via email when it's available for
rejoin we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues who may have
missed today's event until next time
goodbye